hay una gran variedad de lo que
significa ser gay por ejemplo si estoy
en un vestidor y le doy una palmada en
el trasero de un amigo
jubilee presenta
spectrum invitamos a 6 hombres gay para
comprobar el alcance de sus creencias y
valores
[Música]
todo el mundo es un poco gay
321 ya
esta es una difícil porque yo tengo
amigos heterosexuales que no tendrían
nada conmigo inclusive si los considero
atractivos yo sólo bromeo con ellos
diciéndoles yo si lo haría contigo
el pienso sí claro ellos no harían nada
creo que muchos de los chicos heteros
dirían algo como un hombre muy homo él
no es algo tan social si en realidad se
alejaran de eso y experimentarán un poco
por sí mismos podrían descubrir cosas
nuevas bueno la sexualidad en realidad
es un espectro y no creo que haya muchas
cosas dentro del mismo pero sí existen
dos polos opuestos dentro de este así
que creo que las personas se identifican
muy muy heterosexuales son muy muy gay y
la razón por la que estoy aquí
es por lo que acabas de decir es un
espectro así que hay una gran variedad
de lo que significa ser gay por ejemplo
si estoy en un vestidor y le doy una
palmada en el trasero a un amigo es gay
las personas nacen siendo gays
hola chicos bueno creo que esta es una
pregunta polifacética porque considero
que el ser gay no es sólo porque te
sientes atraído sexualmente también es
parte de toda la experiencia así que si
se descubren a sí mismos y se dan cuenta
de que tal vez podrían tener una
relación con alguien del mismo sexo
significa que se convirtieron por arte
de magia en bío que nacieron así sin
duda estoy de acuerdo no creo que las
personas nazcan siendo gay
sin embargo pienso que las mismas nacen
con ciertas tendencias que pueden
encaminar los hacerlo si es que esto
tiene sentido el ser un poco más
sensible o el no tener interés en los
deportes pero sí en las artes es como un
cubo de rubik resulta que tienes contigo
todas estas piezas cuando naces pero eso
no te hace que y entonces en ese sentido
dirías que ser gay es una elección
porque eso es una elección porque puedes
preguntarle a un heterosexual cerca y
por un día no es una opción creo que
están tocando más que los aspectos
sexuales también están los aspectos
culturales como los hábitos de ser gay
pienso que son cosas adquiridas cultura
y te sientes muy cómodo y con las que te
expresas desde mi punto de vista de la
sexualidad esta se desarrolla en la
pubertad y no cuando sales del vientre
materno en plan y vamos a tener sexo
digo eres un niño y estás
desarrollándolo y esto crece a la medida
que lo haces solo tienes que ser solo
tienes que ser quién eres prefiero
hombres masculinos 3 2 1
[Música]
personalmente soy muy femenino una
persona extravagante así que tener esa
misma energía con otra persona no me
parece muy atractivo quiero encontrar a
alguien que sea diferente único y
alguien de quien pueda aprender así que
tener a alguien que es casi idéntico o
similar a mí siento que no crecería lo
suficiente estoy en esta línea porque
quiero a alguien igual a mí me
identifico como un hombre masculino así
que pienso que la razón por la cual
estoy muy de acuerdo es porque quiero
esa equidad en mi relación con un hombre
masculino pienso que si hay mucha
atracción innata en lo que te gusta para
lo que naciste pero creo que hay mucho
más pienso que existe mucha presión
social de la que ni siquiera te das
cuenta que ocurre de manera consciente
lo que debería gustarte también lo hago
con hombres y me di cuenta diciendo
espera porque me gusta esto estoy siendo
influenciado cuando crecía
los hombres gays eran definidos como
femeninos y yo era feminista tenía
muchas características femeninas cuando
era joven y saben fui señalado por eso y
también era acosado pero siempre me
atrajo la gente que era masculina no sé
si era porque si eran personas femeninas
me recordaban partes de mí que no me
gustaban pero creo que pudo haber sido
eso uno uno se siente atraído por lo que
le gusta creo que no hay mucha
lógica en ellos grande no es sano
321 ya
pienso que grandes grandes y las
aplicaciones de citas son un tema muy
complejo creo que hay cosas buenas y
cosas malas creo que lo malo supera lo
bueno así que granger por la forma en
que está configurada es una aplicación
muy basada en el enganche así que me
enseñó a ver a los hombres gays más como
objetos para tener sexo que como
personas reales bueno yo soy más del
tipo romántico soy de los que está un
largo tiempo con alguien así que el
hecho de que muchos de los chicos con
los que salí sólo querían sexo creo que
tiene mucho que ver con
las aplicaciones de citas como grinder
donde solo se basa en el sexo creo que
alimenta ese fuego sexual que muchos
hombres gay parecen tener creo que
tienen que haber más espacios
en los que los hombres gays puedan
conocerse am
soy un padre gay tengo una hija de 18
años y un hijo de 13 años cuando crecía
la idea de que un hombre gay creciera y
se casara y fuera monógamo y fuera feliz
y tuviera hijos era inconcebible y
cuando mi esposo y yo am
empezamos a tener nuestros hijos nos
reunimos con el club para hablar y eran
hombres homosexuales que querían ser
padres no fue hasta ese momento que
finalmente encontré mi lugar fue como
dios mío ellos son como yo no eran
ningún tipo de estereotipo gay sólo
querían tener familias y eso es lo que
no se ve en grande ero en cualquier otro
sitio el mes del orgullo es necesario
321 ya
estoy en cierto modo en desacuerdo
porque creo que el mes del orgullo era
necesario porque estábamos en una época
en la que a los gays no se les permitía
hacer quiénes son y básicamente todo lo
que somos ahora y eso es genial creo que
el mes del orgullo fue bueno cuando lo
necesitábamos y es bueno mantener las
tradiciones pero creo que a veces va
demasiado lejos para mí personalmente
salir del armario creo que para todos es
un proceso desde el momento en que te
das cuenta que eres gay hasta que con
suerte puedes aceptarlo hubo años en los
que nunca me acercaba al orgullo me
desviaba a seis manzanas para que no me
asociaron con el grupo porque me daba
mucho miedo y fue un proceso gradual la
primera vez que lo hice fue el momento
más emocionante de formar parte de miles
de personas yo también tuve la misma
sensación
creo que el orgullo es muy importante
porque tenemos más derechos que hace
50-60 años pero todavía no somos iguales
en muchos lugares y todavía no somos
iguales a los ojos de mucha gente y el
orgullo es como cualquier día solo
tienes que ser tú mismo de forma
auténtica sin ninguna pregunta y
luchando por lo que crees es muy
importante que todos los días te sientas
orgulloso de lo que eres que lo exprese
si intentas cambiar el mundo con lo que
puedes hacer
jubilee vive intensamente